we can be happier without some K protein
turned out it was a long year for us and
we came a long way we're just so happy
with how it turned out especially
visually we felt like as a gameplay team
that we had to step up this year winning
takes talent obviously to repeat like
this takes character that's something
that this team is going to do this year
it's something that they've always done
2k14 with group seed really high praises
we came out graphically animation wise
and we set out to kind of really top
down even for 15 the biggest competitor
for us is ourselves you want to put out
a better game that will be there last
year
start of the year and told the guides
that we really wanted to have a game
that was balanced and that that was that
felt good on both ends of the floor this
year we have a new technology called
situational tech so with this technology
we've been able to rewrite keifa's we've
changed up how we're rotating on defense
how early we rotate we've incorporated
things like defensive IQ player IQ we
like to think that it's kind of a new
living in breathing organism count so
the AI is able to recognize things
they're able to see things on the court
that a user can see
for 2k15 we captured over 5,000
animations contact animations in the
paint on the floor between the ball
handler and the defender just going to
the rim is a lot more visceral defense
collision we really didn't leave any
tables unturned as far as the upgrades
of concern
I think what fans are going to love most
about NBA 2k15 is just the overall
experience everything has been touched
from top to bottom four modes to online
and especially game play there's just so
much in there it's such a forty future
game while we're competitive and really
mirrors real-life basketball on a daily
basis we have this challenge that we
have to face and making sure that we
live up to that and that's the
difference that's why you get a great
product year after year is this the
determination to be the best and just
the love and passion for basketball